hey y'all
movie retrospective time and this was
the one that you guys voted on this week
this was an interesting pick because you
know as i've mentioned before
what i've started doing like now that we
have the uh the patrons like voting on
what movie we're gonna do
i have like a little box and i went
through shutter i went through netflix i
went through 2b
and like all the horror movies that were
on there some that i'd seen like some
that i hadn't seen for a long time but
wanted to like revisit and stuff and i
wrote them all on little pieces of paper
and i put them in a box and then every
week i take five of them out at random
and then put them in the poll
so this week's poll this one came out on
top i think it just beat black sunday by
one vote
now i thought that i had seen this movie
but watching it i don't think i did but
the weird thing about it is that
the um the cover of it is almost it's
kind of like iconic i used to see it a
lot like in the video store when i was
growing up
and i don't think i ever rented it no i
didn't i i saw that cover all the time
yeah and just passed on it wasn't
interested
you know um and haven't seen the movie
it was a little bit disappointing i mean
it it was this [ __ ] this movie should
have been really good it could have been
really good
it had all the makings of a good
australian mad max type
apocalypse post-apocalyptic movie but i
just gotta say it didn't quite deliver
i mean it was about a half i enjoyed
like the first half hour of it
and yeah it started to kind of unravel
for me
it got boring i feel like the beginning
and the end were good but in the middle
it was kind of saggy
i mean it's you know what i mean okay so
we're talking about dead end driving
in case you guys didn't know now the
interesting thing about this
is that so the poster the iconic poster
that we're talking about that has like
that gothy looking dude
like the big face and like the little
drive-in at the bottom okay the driving
at the bottom that's in the movie
that dude i'm pretty sure is not in the
movie no i didn't i didn't see anybody
that looked like that at the moment
i guess i guess the starting i guess
they didn't figure he was quite good
looking enough so they put somebody else
on or they wanted somebody that looked
more i mean because there's like a lot
of punks and like new waivers and stuff
because this was made in 1986.
yeah so maybe it was one of them but it
i mean it could have been that person
but he was like an extra if
there's this australian chick star and
then her last name is mccurry she's
natalie mercury
natalie mccurry she's some australian
beauty queen she's great in it
um cute as a bug i mean and i liked her
character in the movie
yeah jenny and i were talking i was like
man that's exactly the kind of girl i
was looking for in high school
because he gives her a zippo and she's
like oh yeah you know you're the best
[Laughter]
she was feminine everything but she was
kind of she was kind of a tough tom girl
you know what i mean which yeah i was
big into that yeah that's really fun
yeah but you didn't find girls like that
in real life yeah there was just movie
girls yeah this movie girl
she sadly passed away in 2014 we
discovered one yeah when we imdb'd her
yeah i think we
were watching cancer just said a long
illness
probably cancer well you said that she
had been involved in like some breast
cancer like fundraising and stuff so i'm
assuming yeah assuming that's what it
was breast cancer which is
like really sad because she was like
really adorable yeah she died young yeah
she's only two years older than me yeah
wow and she died like what six years ago
seven years ago something like that yeah
so yeah she was dinner 40 still yeah she
was actually um
she was like uh miss australia like back
in the eight
like 70s or 80s and then she was on uh
an australian tv show i think but i
can't remember the name but i think it
was called chances
maybe we didn't get it over here but um
so she was kind of known
but so this movie it's interesting too
because everywhere that i see this movie
come out like arrow video has done like
a nice blu-ray of it
like you know with um with uh you know
interviews with the director and
and everything but uh who's brian
trenchard smith who also directed knight
of the demons 2
and leprechaun 4 in space among other
things
so this one i'm imagining is a lot
better than those but um
i can't really say i haven't seen i saw
none of the demons too it was all right
but um so this everywhere you look like
the
the genre of this movie is always pl put
as horror but this is not a horror movie
not by any stretch it's very much like
mad max
one but without like the uh the car
crashes and the high adrenaline action
it attempts it in that first half hour
it kind of comes close but then once it
starts getting into the uh
they ended up getting getting imprisoned
in a drive-in basically
a drive-in full of [ __ ] young people
they're all like punk rockers and golf
people
and uh most of them don't want to escape
because there's too many goddamn cute
girls in there
well and they're getting fed and it's
like yeah i mean we'll kind of get into
that in a minute so
it's weird how they kind of seemed like
they marketed this as a horror movie but
it's really not it's really like a
dystopian
um comedy drama action movie
i think you missed the last like the
last part of it there was actually like
a really good
um car chase like through the through
the thing like where uh the main
character
whose name is jimmy but he's known as
krabs yeah and for exactly the reason
that
you thank you
[Laughter]
it got so boring and so slow for me that
i said hold on i'm gonna go get somebody
and i walked out to go make something to
eat and i missed the end but see you
missed the best part yeah that might
have been the best part but
that's not how movies work yeah
they're supposed to pull you in you're
supposed to get kind of immersed into in
them you're supposed to care about
what's going to happen
by the time i was an hour into it i
really didn't care what was going to
happen
i'd already passed the best part and
that's when they were screwing in the
car
that's the best part yeah there were
some titties she had nice proportions
very nice proportions yeah one of the
other girls had like one of the other
extras
i think she showed her boobs too yeah
like briefly
yeah but yeah there's no there's no gore
there's nothing like that but it's more
like it kind of gave me
you know yes it's clearly like a mad max
off kind of not i don't know if it'd rip
off but it's homage maybe
yeah also gave me kind of a cherry 2000
that's what i was gonna boy and his dog
kind of vibe too
yeah look you could run it in the same
universe as cherry 2000 boy his dog
mad max one the tone is more like cherry
2000 though
that's yeah it could it was kind of like
reminding me of that very strongly
man backs one is a little darker even
though it had humor in it it was
mad max 1 had a had a real dark tone to
it that of course is iconic you know
what i mean
yeah this one was a little goofier i
feel like i'm scary 2 000
yeah that's i think that's the the movie
that this reminded me of most strongly
so it's like it's not really it's not
post-apocalyptic
um in the sense that there's been a
nuclear war or like a disease that wiped
everyone out
it's just like a dystopia i think it was
supposed to be
i couldn't figure out if it was supposed
to be set in the 1990s
or the early 2000s because like at the
beginning they had a thing
that they were like um 1987 there was
this big economic crash
and then you know there was like mass
unemployment everything so it's more
kind of a sense of
you know the world hasn't been wiped out
but everything's just kind of gone to
[ __ ]
it's the future from the point of view
of the 80s right right right uh
it's definitely not the future though
and uh it's
it's the same situation as mad max in
mad max it never clearly says
that there was a huge nuclear war yeah
that there was like a cataclysm yeah
there was a bunch of stuff you know and
mad max one
australia was falling apart because the
criminal justice system was falling
apart
and it doesn't really explain why that's
happening it's just that society is like
an
unraveling it's just gangs you know
yeah um and then later on in
the road warrior the feral kid who's
telling you his version of the history
of the world
says that it was great wars between
great tribes
and the black oil stopped coming and the
machines stopped
you know and there was turmoil it was
just a general apocalypse
so from that point of of you you could
say it was post-apocalypse
it was just mad max's version of what
the apocalypse was yeah
there was some nuclear stuff but that's
not what that's not really what it was
it was a mixture of a bunch of stuff
which might have been the case here
because it's almost like no one really
said anything about there being a
nuclear war because like i said it says
that you know there's a little text at
the beginning that says like there was
an economic crash and oil blah blah
but it didn't say anything about a war
it didn't say anything about that but a
lot of the shots
like look kind of like posted by in with
that orange filter
yeah you know what i mean i will say
like the cinematography on this that
is very very nice yeah but here's
something else you know i mean
in mad max 1 mad max 2 3 and 4 like fury
road
it's the apocalypse is unraveling and
getting worse as it goes
it couldn't have been a nuclear war
because
there was no real water left on the
earth the nuclear war wouldn't do that
yeah something environmental
environmental
it's kind of like the earth has shifted
on its [ __ ] axis or something and it
lost a lot of its water
so there's yeah i you know we we're led
to believe that it's
a normal apocalypse just with radiation
and [ __ ]
because they're out in the desert and
you're assuming that it's the outback
but it may have been that that really
wasn't the outback maybe
most of the [ __ ] earth was like that
they just had to be filming it in the
outback if you understand what i'm
talking about yeah i know you're talking
about yeah but i think they
it could have been that in road warrior
yeah just the landscape looks like
post-apocalypse whether they met it
or not yeah yeah i think i think in
um road warrior and in um the other mad
max movies it came after like it was a
[ __ ]
i think those two movies i think well it
basically says that you know there's a
little
little oasis where all little kids are
living it's it's basically trying to say
that the entire
earth is a desert yeah and a nuclear
exchange won't do that
yeah that's like like you said that's an
environmental cause more of an
environmental thing
whereas in this movie dead and drive-in
it seems more like an economic collapse
because it seems like people still like
have houses and [ __ ]
and people still have jobs but it seems
like they're making
um the director is kind of making a
statement about
like not only the degeneration like you
know none of the
young people can find jobs it's like you
know it's kind of like a shitty
situation and there's like a lot of
youth gangs and [ __ ] like that
but um he's also kind of making the
thing like very early on like the main
character jimmy
he has like a muscle-bound brother frank
who had like actually one of the best
lines in the movie like he comes
he comes to work out he lifts this the
the barbell up like a minute
he's doing curls and he and then he's
like yeah why bother marty strong enough
yeah which i thought was very funny yeah
but yeah
he's big enough yeah he's strong i think
so he's so he is like a tow truck driver
and very early on him and jimmy go out
on a run
and you can see that basically what
happens
is that there's these gangs of youths
that just utes
that just kind of like drive around you
know being crazy and like setting [ __ ]
on fire and
whatnot and um so the tow trucks will
come
and to these big accidents and then
they'll be like
rival like tow truck drivers but they
don't care about like the people that
got killed in the car because there's
like all these gnarly bodies like
hanging out of the [ __ ] car and
everything
they just care about like who got there
first so who's gonna get like the scrap
rights for the cars
so it's they're kind of making a
statement about how you know in this
world like
things are more important than people
are like you know what i mean like yeah
like
like road warrior yeah so it's so it's
basically the same
so what ends up happening like after
that um
is that jimmy uh unbeknownst to his
brother frank steals his very awesome
was it what was it a 1957 it's yeah it's
a 1957 chevy like red and white
he's still the cars i did not recognize
they're they're well because they were
australian australian fords and stuff so
there's different versions so
they had different versions that we had
yeah things things that looked kind of
like mustangs they weren't falcons but
at least they weren't a falcon xb maybe
they were pelicans i don't know
i just realized that we reviewed an
australian movie last week too
like mungo that was also i thought that
was a total accident
but um but yeah so he takes
frank's beautiful beautiful car uh
without frank knowing
so he can take his girlfriend carmen
like we said played by natalie mccurry
to the drive-in now unbeknownst to him
they have a little sign like at the at
the entrance of the drive-in saying like
regular people have to pay ten dollars
unemployed
can pay like three it's 350 or something
like that
so the trick is that if you tell them
you're unemployed you get in cheaper
then they won't let you leave because
essentially this drive-in
is a prison camp for unemployed youth
you know what i mean because they just
they just want to keep them in there
like to keep them off the streets
yeah so but the thing about it though is
that
most of the people there don't really
want to leave
because like they don't have jobs to go
out to they don't you know they have
their cars in there they set up a little
thing
they give them meal tickets they show
movies you know they have
it's a big orgy too and they're having
all kinds of [ __ ] fun basically
right and it's like so they've so it's
basically made like this little
everyone's made little hovels out of
their cars and it's like they're cooking
and this you know there's trade and
there's drugs and
you know the the guy that manages the
drive-in like we'll give you beer and
if you were 17 you'd love it that's why
you want out that's what i mean so most
of them don't want to leave
yeah and the thing about it is that i
mean jimmy
even though his life isn't like super
fantastic like out like his
he's got a mom like his mom's italian
like and his he loves his brother and
[ __ ] like that nigga's rossini
yeah i think it was yeah but that was
another funny scene where
him and his brother were at the table
and they were eating spaghetti with
their very italian mom and she was like
why are you so small you're not like
your brother you know
you're talking about how like he's like
i'm getting bigger i'm getting bigger
thinking bigger i'm bulking up i'm not
yeah he's like eating he's trying
like the size difference is amazing his
brother's like [ __ ] two feet taller
than him
he wasn't that small of a guy he wasn't
that small and his brother was huge
yeah they i think that's why they cast
like so they would look like a lot just
because he doesn't look that
he's not like out of shape obviously
because he's like runner he's a runner
and stuff but
he's like a lot smaller than his brother
is so
so jimmy aka krabs is really the only
person
who when he figures out finally that
they're not allowed to leave this
drive-in because there's like
electrified fences and like the cops
like the cops come and took the wheels
off his car basically so he couldn't get
out
and then like it's all surrounded by
electrified fence and that you know the
cops are kind of in on it and they're
paying
the manager of the drive-in like to keep
them all in there
but like i said nobody wants to leave
because they don't have anywhere else to
go
and one of the big um things is that
jimmy and his girlfriend carmen like as
soon as she figures out like you know
we're not supposed to leave she's like
whatevs yeah she didn't care
well because i they established early on
that she had actually i think she had
run away from home
yeah um and her parents were looking for
her and she didn't want them to find her
so she was like totally not bothered
she's just like okay well we'll just
stay here and
we'll have food given to us we can watch
movies every night there's beer there's
drugs there's
other people she made friends with like
some of the other girls in the bathroom
they did her hair and [ __ ] like that so
she was like why should i go anywhere
it's like so much nicer in here but i
think like what
the director of the movie and he i think
he's even said that like said this like
on
in documentaries and stuff was that he
was kind of trying to say that you know
the world had got so shitty
that that's all that these like
teenagers even though they were clearly
on their 20s or 30s
like that's kind of all they had to look
forward to like this quote unquote junk
culture or trash culture where they
would just like watch these shitty
movies and like eat shitty food and like
not really care about
bettering themselves or not really care
about getting out of
it you know what i mean so they're
almost like normal normal kids
yeah well yeah i was like i kind of
swear
we were and then like you know later on
they kind of get a little bit into
although it's weird because they kind of
toward the end of the movie when they
started bringing in
um you know like some asian people like
you know into like they started busting
them in and like putting them in the
thing
yeah and then like kind of all the
whities started getting all like butt
hurt about it like getting all national
front or whatever
they had in australia at the time um and
it's really weird because you're trying
to start a race
race yeah that's right but it's like
it's really weird because they kind of
went with that and then it's like it
didn't really kind of go anywhere
like it was just kind of like there
wasn't any reason
that's a lot of that's a lot of the
problem of this movie is that it would
come up with
ideas that you would think it was going
to be important and maybe it would go
somewhere but
they wouldn't and there was a lot of
opportunities to take this into a really
interesting direction but
it didn't really do it i mean i think
that really the whole thing about
i mean the whole thing about them
introducing that because it was pretty
late in the movie that they did that
i think it was just one showing that
like some of the people that were
already picking on jimmy were dicks
which we already knew because they had
tried to kill him
but also i think it was just so that all
that most of the white kids at the um
drive-in
would all be in one place because they
were all having some little
white person meeting or something um so
they would all be in one place
well it was australia most people were
white yeah well no i'm just saying that
they wanted them all in one place so
that jimmy the main character
like for him for all them to be in there
so he could make his like final escape
because he like stole a police vehicle
and they chased him all around the um
drive-in
and [ __ ] like that which like i said you
missed that because that was actually
like pretty good
and one of the stunt men that worked on
this i think was also one of the
sentiment of
uh mad max 2 uh you know road warrior
so um you know so they did have that
going and some of the stunts were like
actually pretty amazing um
you know at that sense but as you said
like the beginning of it was good
because i liked like a lot of the
character establishments like
before they got to the drive-in like
when they first got to the drive-in
like the interactions between him and
his girlfriend the interactions between
him and his brother
but once he got there and you know
started talking to the manager it seemed
to take him a really long time
to figure out that they couldn't leave
or figure out what was going on
and you think that that would be very
easy to figure out wouldn't take him
very long
right i think part of it was i think
part of what happened was is that
the location is pretty good for the
movie
the cast and the the costumes and all
those cars it looks really good
it's a gorgeous looking movie he's even
shot really well
yeah and i think that's the downfall of
the movie he's trying to keep it in that
location where all this good [ __ ]
[ __ ] is
but that kind of [ __ ] up your story
because it's now
confined into this one location there's
not much you can really do
with the story yeah that's what i think
happened with it
it needed to remain a mobile story
outside
i didn't i just didn't like the yeah
the driving thing should have just been
a scene of a few minutes if you ask me
yeah i mean i like the concept of them
like kind of
you know closing everybody into this
drive-in and then like a lot of the kids
not wanting to leave and that being the
conflict
but i feel like he could have done more
with that because like i said it really
does seem like
it took a really long time where he was
just kind of like hanging around
trying to get wheels for his car so he
could leave there was a little bit of
conflict because his girlfriends didn't
want to leave and he didn't really want
to leave her there
there was some conflict with some of the
other like guys
at the drive-in who didn't like him
because he was new or whatever
so it's like there was a little bit of
that but it just seemed like there
wasn't enough of it to sustain
yeah the middle act of the film but then
like the the third
act like when he was like you know when
the you know racist people were having
their meeting and he was like doing his
escape
that was actually cool like there was
like a lot of really good shots it was
like a really
good stunts there was all that kind of
[ __ ] like all the cars like driving over
[ __ ] and like driving over you know
crashing into things i'm just gonna take
your word for it no it's like it was
cool like the end part was really cool
but that was kind of the main thing that
i had with it was just like the middle
was like it was way too long it was kind
of slow
like the middle was kind of slow like
they could have done it seemed like they
were just like hanging around from the
minute that they
got into the [ __ ] drive-in and then
from the time he gets to the drive and
he escapes that really should only be
about five
seven ten minutes you didn't there's not
much story to tell
inside that drive if you ask me uh this
well i mean you could have come up with
something because like i said he seemed
to have the threads
of some of some stories and conflicts in
there like with his girlfriend not
wanting to leave like
you know the other guys like maybe there
could have been something with them like
you know the other
people that didn't want the asians there
it's like there was like threads of it
but it seems like it wasn't like
developed enough
like to sustain like the middle part of
the movie yeah it's just not really not
important
think about it yeah i mean okay and a
boy with his in
in a boy and his dog he ends up in that
underground uh community
and he was down in there for quite a
while part of the move 15 minutes of the
movie 15 20 minutes
if i remember correctly well a lot
happens down there a bunch of weird [ __ ]
is shown
that kind of draws you into it then you
find out they're going to use him as
breeding stock and then he has to get
out of there
so it was more exciting yeah
you know the just the stories that went
on
inside the the drive in the they weren't
compelling for me
yeah you know i was i got bored with it
by the time he escaped
i didn't care if he escaped or not by
the time that happened
i i think i liked this movie more than
you did but um
i i kind of the the middle of it did
kind of try my patience yeah but
because it like i said it seemed to take
him a very long time to figure out hey
bud
you know you can't get out of here and
like the cops are in on the [ __ ] they're
you know taking the payoff the cops were
like bringing the manager the driving
drugs like to give to the people and
you know there's enough footage there
you could probably re-edit that
maybe take 10 minutes of it out and
[ __ ] reorder certain things and
probably yeah you could just shorten
probably the movie could probably be
fixed i think it's a pacing issue more
than anything else
yeah i don't like i i liked all the
actors i liked all the characters i
liked the concept
um like i said the cinematography is
really really nice um
i liked a lot of the uh the music it was
very new i think they had there was some
hunters and collectors
in there um which if anybody remembers
them i kind of remember them
but um you know so there was a lot of
like really good [ __ ] about this movie
but yeah and like i said it looked
amazing
like and when i figured out when i found
out that that director had also done
like leprechaun 4 and stuff i'm like
i wonder if that one looked as good as
this one but this one like this the shot
setups are like really really nice
and so i do i that's really the only
criticism i have of it
is that it just seemed like the middle
act was too long and there was like two
it's weird to say because it seemed like
nothing happened
but it seemed like a lot of threads were
introduced that they could have done
something with that they didn't really
do anything that's the way to put it
yeah so i think it's pacing issues yeah
i think that's all it was it needs to be
re-edited the the middle act needs to be
re-edited
that's what i think yeah and i've been i
watched a couple of people's like other
uh reviews of it and most people seem to
say about the same thing it's like some
people seem to like it more than others
uh quentin tarantino really likes this
movie for some reason
the first time i heard of this movie
like other than seeing it like in the
in the video store and i don't think i
ever rented it um
remember we watched that uh documentary
called not quite hollywood
the history of osploitation it was all
about australians
they mentioned this one in there yeah
that's right um so that's kind of
so i think i was kind of thinking of
that in the back of my mind and then i
saw that it was on to be so i added it
to the box and then it got voted for
so we uh watched it last night and it's
like like i said i
you know it was cool looking it was a
cool concept i didn't love it
um but i don't know i i might give it
another whirl one of these days but i
really did
the the middle part did seem to go on
like a little bit too long and i feel
like there was
more they could have done with some of
the story lines that they introduced
it might be worth it just to see natalie
mccurry
she is a cutie pie yeah and she's
walking around that little [ __ ] black
pvc dress
you got you got one of those i do like i
think i have one
yeah well mine's not exactly the same
because hers is red hers buttons and
mine ties
like corset ties on the front with red
but other than that it was like the same
color yeah it's a good scene of her
inside the car she's [ __ ] riding on a
dude [ __ ] she's fully nude and [ __ ]
you get a good profile
they're not [ __ ] huge booze but
they're you know they're well-formed
yeah yeah yeah it's funny because every
every time like because he was like
looking down at his thing and like then
one of the other one of the other girls
like she's in the shower
and i said titty alert yeah he's like
what
[Laughter]
she's funny man well you know you need
to weigh in on that [ __ ] it's like let's
let's
get a let's get a rating on well you
know because it was a different check
back back when you were back when you
were 15
16 years old in the [ __ ] pre-internet
porn era
that [ __ ] was sucking yeah all right you
look now you're like yeah okay whatever
yeah there's just everywhere we're
drowning in tits yeah
it's not it's not even nudity by today's
standards yeah
hardly that's true well you know that
was only an american thing anyway pretty
much i think in the uk if i could you
could walk around topless i don't think
you cared about it they had it in it
wasn't it in the tv guide uh yeah the
one newspaper
the page three girl yeah she was uh yeah
they had a different
chick in there it's going look at my
titties like everyone's single yeah that
wouldn't fly in the u.s back in those
days
no you could not show well and you could
show tits on tv back then too and you
could swear on tv like after
8 p.m right 9 p.m something like that no
way you were gonna get away with that
in the united states especially then the
bible belt era
yeah that's right well that's that's why
europeans always thought that we were a
bunch of puritans over here just because
they thought that was the dumbest [ __ ]
ever that was only the bible belt
yeah and it was those people were old
back then
so they're all probably dead yeah
they're all dead now that was like my
grandmother's era
yeah never grandmother's uh not era but
uh her generation
yeah and that boy they were weird i know
they were
they worried about everything they read
into everything
because they were a bunch of like
perverted freaks yeah yeah they read
into everything
well what does that mean why is her hair
blue what does that mean
it means her hair is blue but what does
that mean it doesn't mean anything
they did they always thought there was
like some kind of meaning well like just
because i like it i realized why
though later on i was basically told why
i saw an interview of
of an old guy who grew up in that
generation
and he said colors meant things to that
generation if you wore [ __ ] like
yellow on tuesday it meant you were gay
[Laughter]
if you wore black i remember the earring
thing like if it's is it left is it
right
yeah if you were if you wore black then
that meant you were a criminal
you know what i mean just all kinds of
weird they had all they had all these
[ __ ] weird uh
color codings it has i guess it had to
do with being from a real
repressed society where you couldn't
express things openly
you had to do it in innuendo using color
coding and [ __ ] like that
everything meant something that's like
the neo-nazis with their [ __ ] boot
laces
like all the different colored like boot
laces that might have come from an era
similar to that anyway maybe it did
that's very strange
yeah i don't know it's very weird um
yeah it's because you can't just [ __ ]
say what you are
you know so you had to use all these
[ __ ] weird colors and and so you know
yellow shirt you wanna just like you
know [ __ ] like my dad
even my dad's generation you know when
they were kids you know [ __ ] how long
your hair
was uh indicated whether what your
political
affiliation was were you a [ __ ]
hippie or were you
yeah but this or that and and they just
like that generation could not imagine a
world that didn't give a [ __ ] about that
yeah you know really how long i remember
hearing about like uh stephen king you
say when he was growing up in the 60s
and 70s like he had long
like not long not by today's standards
it was just like over their ears a
little bit and he's like he's to get
beat up all the time like
in bars and [ __ ] it's like i told you
that no matter who you are where you
live
the your the future from your point of
view will be unacceptable
you won't like it and my grandparents
generation if they were around around
today they wouldn't like any of this
[Laughter]
because they wouldn't understand most of
it would it wouldn't go my god
why do they carry these little things oh
[ __ ] the internet that's just
that's just garbage it's all
porn it's all garbage there's nothing
there it is mostly porn i mean to be
honest
i'm just kidding there's cats on there
too
yeah it's just i just i just it's just
you know
we're going off on these um we're going
off
it doesn't matter but yeah so uh if
you're into australian
uh movies and you haven't seen this one
like i said it says it's a horror movie
it's not it's kind of like
if so if you like mad max or cherry 2000
or something like that
um you know you might want to check it
out as i said it's on tubey so you can
watch it for free
and that'll do it for this movie
retrospective we'll see you guys later
bye